or what's in a name mark zuckerberg is
hoping it can mean a new start the
facebook ceo has announced he's changing
the parent company name to meta he says
it's more in line with the tech giant's
virtual reality vision for the future
but skeptics say the rebrand is also an
attempt to forget the scandals that have
cast a shadow on the world's most
powerful social media conglomerate we've
just called it home until now the future
according to mark zuckerberg
virtual worlds in 3d built with his
technology
a future in which the social media
empire that he created will no longer be
called facebook but better
facebook is one of the most used
products in the history of the world
it is an iconic social media brand
but right now our brand is so tightly
linked to one product that it can't
possibly represent everything that we're
doing today let alone in the
future but the facebook brand has also
suffered badly the social network is
accused of failing to remove hate speech
from its platform and of spreading
political strife and misinformation
around the world
facebook employees have gone public
claiming that zuckerberg ignored their
warnings
calls for breaking up facebook's
dominance are getting louder
you don't develop the competitive
products that might protect kids or may
do something about vaccine
misinformation if they buy everything in
sight and our government allows them to
do that the end must come to that
as facebook becomes meta it seems
zuckerberg is hoping a new name will
spell a new beginning for the
beleaguered social media giant
well let's cross over to dw business
reporter christy platson christy welcome
what is facebook a company that made a 9
billion profit last quarter doing here
what exactly will the metaverse be for
them and for us the consumer
yeah great question well uh how
zuckerberg essentially imagines the
metaverse is he imagines a virtual
environment that will allow people to be
present with each other in digital
spaces
what we saw in the announcement
yesterday was uh we saw people
collaborating together in digital
virtual offices we saw people taking the
forms sometime of avatars sometimes of
holograms to attend concerts together to
play games together um so this is a
really visionary idea that facebook is
pushing i should mention they're
not the first ones to think of this idea
but they're certainly one of the largest
and wealthiest companies to get behind
it uh this is going to require a huge
advancements in virtual reality and
augmented reality technology as for what
this means for for facebook on that
level they um they already are have
oculus the virtual reality headset
developer um they acquired that company
and they do plan to sell those devices
but where they really see the money is
actually within the metaverse itself uh
they actually expect uh the metaverse to
essentially become its own functioning
economy where we will buy property
clothing anything you can really think
of for our digital identities and that's
really where this business model is
centered
the rebrand is also coming at a time
where the company is getting a lot of
negative publicity what do we make of
the timing is it coincidental
well i will say that mark zuckerberg has
been talking about this metaverse push
for for some months now so i will give
them a
credit that they probably already had a
name change in mind beforehand but that
being said it's obviously an ideal time
for facebook to
dangle a shiny new toy
in front of the public so to speak we've
seen as you said almost uh non-stop
negative press around a facebook around
meta since this um since this leak so
there's been a lot of public interest
that this shows that the public is very
interested in what facebook has planned
and so it certainly was well timed i'll
say that much
if you are trying to sell a new concept
to the world and make people feel good
about something is mark zuckerberg the
most wise choice what has been the
audience reaction to his sales job here
christy
right
dale's job because what i would have
said is that in this announcement we saw
yesterday it was essentially an almost a
90-minute long sales pitch for the
metaverse it was quite a bizarre uh
bizarre
presentation that we saw there was a lot
of cgi it was quite scripted very
kitschy at some points um and uh yeah i
don't think that mark zuckerberg came
over in particularly more uh warmer
charming than he has in the past uh but
that being said uh facebook or now meta
has always been zuckerberg's brainchild
and he's really positioned himself
as very much integral to the company's
vision this is really his idea and i
don't know that there was really another
option for who could have presented this
idea which is going to be so pivotal for
this company ultimately it starts and
ends with mark which is something we
actually heard from the whistleblower a
few weeks ago when she spoke in congress
christy platson from dw business thanks
so much
thanks
you